je vous le dis on a été souvent en
guerre avec Thierry mais comme je disais
hier pour Yannick Noah moi au moins
tirade ils sont on en a besoin je suis
désolé les mecs il dit des trucs que
personne ne dit au moins il ouvre sa
gueule il y a que des mecs quand ils
font des interviews c'est inintéressant
possible Yannick Noah j'ai aimé son
interview ma mine de rien voilà il a dit
des trucs qu'il a et l'attirait Ardisson
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas c'est
vrai que quand même il y va ça nous
c'est des personnalités qu'on aime bien
je suis désolé on en a tellement dans la
tellement de personnalités qui servent à
rien et toi quand il est plus à la télé
comme je t'ai dit
arrête arrête de Twitter
hashtag
Twitter ça existait sur C8
et son contraire parce que dans le même
interview il dit pour justifier les
mauvaises audiences de cette du temps
pardon il a dit oui non que les gens ont
adoré sur Twitter donc là il s'est servi
Twitter
absurde moi ce que j'aime c'est les mecs
qui disent oui leurs commentaires qui
sont en roulis dans les interviews
Twitter c'est de la merde comme ça c'est
génial comme ça après Twitter si c'est
ni tout bon ni tout mauvais ce que je
dis à chaque fois il y a des avis très
simple très intéressants sur Twitter il
y a des gens qui donnent de très bons
conseils sur Twitter qui qui disent des
trucs vraiment et des vannes il y a des
vannes incroyables sur tous les
aventures franchement il y a des mecs
très très drôle sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis il y a des mecs qui sont là que
pour insulter après c'est à toi de faire
le tube tu peux pas dire Twitter c'est
tout bon ou tout mauvais
pour moi aussi comme ça aurait été chez
bon comme ça l'arrange pas c'est mauvais
c'est sur les réseaux toi Josiane ou pas
oui ma fille m'a fait une page Facebook
avec une faute d'orthographe à mon
prénom
donc c'est bien
la page Instagram
on n'est pas potes mais c'est vrai que
il a dit quoi il a dit ouais il a une
tête de télé comme Pascal pro aussi mais
pas du tout c'est très bien
avec tout le monde aujourd'hui
il y en a trois dans le métier qui est
qui franchement il envoie et envoie
son émission c'était sa balance pas mal
bien sûr tu as rien tu as Thierry
Laurent Ruquier je suis désolé il dit
voilà il avait un mec il aime il aime
pas il aime pas mettre dans ses
démissions c'est le seul qui fait des
sorties où il envoie du lourd et je suis
désolé tu as quand même Laurent Bignolas
ce qui a donné ce soir
quand même une énorme importance à
Twitter même nous regarder tous les
soirs avec les sondages oui mais moi
mais moi en fait les rédactions même sur
BFM mais moi je comprends et tous les
gens qui votent en fait tous les gens
qui votent je le vois ils font des
commentaires c'est pas des commentaires
haineux moi je vois un livre blanc qui
vote sur TPMP etc il donne leur avis moi
j'adore Twitter parce que ça donne c'est
un sondage on dirait c'est incroyable je
suis désolé c'est un outil incroyable
des gens connus tu peux pas une émission
avant d'aller 80 on faisait une ligne
éditoriale et tout le monde fermait sa
gueule aujourd'hui Twitter tu peux dire
je suis pas content je suis content je
fais insulter celui qui insulte tu le
blocs tu le dégage après vous voulez
Twitter que quand il y a des compliments
exactement
on est tout content poste une photo tu
es beau gosse tu es gentil tu es bien
sûr un moment tu as bien un mec qui va
te fracasser vraiment c'est beaucoup
plus fracassé
moi sur Twitter et tout et sur insta je
vois des il y a des talons de ouf je
vous jure que il y a des mecs qui
sortent des vannes trucs incroyable il y
a des vannes de ouf je me dis les
mecs ils sont trop forts il y a des
montages qui sont faits des vidéos il y
a il y a énormément de talents quand
même sur les réseaux sociaux après bien
sûr tout n'est pas bon c'est comme dans
tout hein regardez c'est comme tout
n'est pas bon comme dans le cochon je
suis désolé alors il y a quel niveau qui
voulait faire une analyse non c'est pas
si si allez-y non vous qui regardez tout
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors moi qui
regarde tout quand tu quand vous
comparez Instagram Twitter Facebook etc
on est quand même sur Twitter quelque
chose qui réunit
une énorme proportion de de gros cons
de commenter des choses qui sont
malheureux qui déversent leur haine la
raison des
idiots des vraiment
c'est la majorité parce que moi qui suit
énormément sur Instagram et Tik Tok
Facebook qui connaît tous les autres
réseaux celui-ci c'est un gros ramassis
de cons ça chez le quand même alors je
vous dis je vais défendre Twitter moi
parce que bien sûr je vous dis moi pas
Twitter par vous-même c'est différent
comme partout mais Twitter il y a des
Vans incroyables il y a des mecs bien
sûr il y a des mecs qui critiquent et
cetera mais il y a aussi des analyses
parfois qui sont intéressantes et il y a
des choses intéressantes sur Twitter
aussi après voilà Twitter c'est surtout
un un réseau social
pour donner plus son avis donc forcément
tu as des mecs qui vont qui vont
défoncer sur insta c'est pas pareil ni
tiktoker Tik Tok ça n'a rien à voir le
physique
pas exactement
c'est de l'opinion
toutes les émissions
de télé fonctionnerait pas avec les
hashtags les problèmes qu'on a d'accord
c'est pas Twitter je désolé Twitter je
vous le jure moi je le vois je vois des
trucs incroyables sur Twitter il y a des
gens très bien qui sont sur Twitter et
des mecs qui sont inconnus qui font des
trucs de ouf sur Twitter et qui sont
très drôles l'autre le problème c'est
parfois les mois pour moi les les
gugusses les Guignols ils sont c'est
parfois il y a des mecs des journalistes
qui prennent par exemple 4 tweets de
mecs de gugus ça ils disent qu'ils
disent du mal d'une émission et qui s'en
sert pour faire un article pour moi
l'aiguille c'est plus ces journalistes
là que les mecs sur Twitter c'est voilà
c'est quand il y aura ils font beaucoup
de mal d'ailleurs au métier de
journalistes les amis de Valérie Benaim
voilà donc je vous dis donc voilà
les amis également de gilberté ah non
c'est pas mes amis
faut lever l'anonymat merci botob à toi
lève-toi tout court et toi